はーい、 という訳で沖縄から帰ってきたんですけども
あの、お知らせがあります
動画のタイトルの通り
しばらく動画をお休みさせていただきます
今までありがとうございまし た
辞めねーけどなあ！！！！
まあ辞めないんですけども、すいませんあのー
ちょっと スケジュール が いっぱい いっぱい すぎて
動画を出す時間が全く ございません
って なんか最近 てか、もうね
実の話を言うとね
3 月の後半から もう忙しすぎて あの正直
あの メイン の動画に
割く時間がないんですよぉ(笑)
やばくね？なんかもう
本末転倒感は あるんですけども
まあ、しゃーないです
しゃーないことだと思って 僕は今ぐっと こらえてるところでは あったんですけど
もう 何かこらえてるのも
ちょっともう いいやと思っちゃって
なんか 中途半端 に 忙しくて
無理やり動画 出すぐらい だったらもう休もうと思って
1 週間ほど ちょっと 動画 お休みさせていただきます
まあ いろんな  理由 が あるんですけども
全然もう モチベはありますよ！！
何ならもう やりたい 動画 山ほど あるんですけど
やる時間がない！！！！
はい
どれくらい 忙しいかと 言いますとね
これが3月末のスケジュール なんですよ
序盤は ちょっと まぁまぁ空いてたりしたんですけど
後半 から おやおや？？？
おや？って 感じで もう怒涛の撮影スケジュール
撮影やらイベントやらミーティングやら
僕がメインの動画を撮る以外のことが
ここに書いてあるんですけど
なんかいろんな場所に行ったり
撮影したりミーティングしたりで
3月の後半からね
27しか休みが なかったのかな
4月も えっと、
5，6，7，8，9 動画結構色々 撮れたと思うんですけど そこから また 怒涛のスケジュール で
今 が21日で もう この 先 ですね
21,22,23,24,25,26,27,28まで
ノンストップで ちょっと
忙しすぎて無理して動画 撮るぐらい だったら 素直に
あきらめようということで、一週間
動画以外のことを 頑張らせていただきます
やばくね？！このスケジュール！！！
改めて見たんですけど みて、
もう3月と4月見ると もう真っ青！！！
私 どういうスケジュールをとっているかといいますと
この青いスケジュールをちょっとでも
これだけは やらなきゃいけないんで やって、
そん中の余った時間で 畑の動画を撮り
メインの動画を撮り ってやってると
畑は みんな人がいるから
人がいるうちに撮りたくて 撮っちゃうと
メインの時間がねぇ
ないんです☆
もう なんか そもそも 毎日 動画を出すこと 自体 不可能なんじゃねー かって 思ってたんですけど ちょっと
ゴールデンウィークは動画 出したいなと 思ってるんで
ゴールデンウィーク前の まあ この1 週間  かなぁ
畑のほうは ちゃんと 出てると 思うんですけど
まぁ メイン は ちょっとね 自分やりたいことをね
凝って ちゃんと やりたいんで 無理に動画を出して
がっかりしてもらうのも 嫌なんで
ちょっと しっかりと1 週間 えっと 活動休止にさせて
何ならもう活動はバンバンするんですけど
メインチャンネル の動画投稿は
ちょっとストップさせていただきます
うん、中途半端な時間で
できるようなものではないと思うので
こうゆうことになってくるわけですよ、YouTuberは
まあ、これが良いか悪いかで言うと僕は
ありがたいことではあるんですけども
良いと思ってないんで
動画出せないのやばくない？
そう、あと最近、熱出したんですよね
なん か 38℃の 熱出したんで
なんか ちょっと 無理しちゃだめだなと思ってるんで
ちょっと しっかりとここは
目の前にある仕事を
丁寧にこなしていきたいと思います
困ったから
動画 出せないの困ったなぁ
まぁ 一応 でもそういう ちゃんと 理由 が あるので
大丈夫だと思うんですけど
すいません、僕ちょっと忙しいんですよ (´;ω;｀)
でも忙しいアピールってわけじゃなくてー
純粋に「なんで忙しいか」っていう理由は
この通りです
1 週間たったらいつも通り 復活するんですけど
すいません、この一週間は
別のお仕事に集中させてください
もちろん、その中に動画とかもあるんですけどね
と いう 感じでござい ます
忙しいアピールとかしたくないんですけど
これ忙しいアピールしないと
みんな 絶対
「はじめ さぼってんじゃん」
「ゲームとカードに遊んでんだろうな」
って言われるんで
言わざるを得ないんで
ちゃんと 理由として言わせていただきました
とゆーわけで皆さん
1 週間後に お会いしましょう(泣)
しばしのお 別れです
ばいばい(´;ω;｀)
東京行ってきます
ぴょぉん